hi my name is aimy Nurnberger I'm the
reshapes David manager here at Columbia
University as it was in the Center for
Digital research and scholarship one of
our main projects is the academic
comments which is Columbia University's
research repository so we have some
experience with working with a variety
of documents document types datasets and
things like that so we'll talk talking a
little bit about that but I have to be
honest when I first heard about this
project the first thing that popped into
my mind is a path right what is
education
but a pass from ignorance to knowledge
and what are syllabi except for
essentially a map of that path what is
the landmarks that you're going to hit
on your way during this course but as I
read more about the open syllabus
project and looked at their website what
I saw and said with this this is that
syllabi are the DNA of the teaching
Enterprise and I thought a little about
about that and like really is that is
that a metaphor we're going to use for
these things is it is it really a good
one but and I thought a little bit more
about that and it occurred to me there
was this quote I remember sharing on
Nova because Nova is just a wonderful
place to share things that DNA is
basically a parts list and if we look at
how the open syllabus projects are
presenting these syllabi not as open
full-text necessarily but as metadata
drawn from the syllabi that is in
essence what we're getting here is a
parts list of what is making up these
educational endeavors right and so
looking at it like this you don't know
you know how someone travels along that
path but you start getting a sense of
what those parts what are those
components that make up these courses
that makes that make up the journey
through the education and this is
actually really interesting because what
we can end up doing that is we ingest
all these syllabi and they go into this
database and you know then we're able to
to structure api's over this where we
can put certain queries to it and we get
answers out about this parts list and
there are some some questions that have
already been proposed up there you know
and I think there there are others and
the parts list kind of idea is really
fascinating because once you have all of
these parts what's the next really
interesting thing is what are people
doing with these parts it might not be
what you ever expected it might be
something really new and and where
you're really starting to build on this
and take advantage of this as consider
who are the community who's making up
that community that you're presenting
these parts to and i think joe presented
this a little bit well at the very
beginning when he said well who are the
audience's that we're dealing with right
we're dealing with educators that's some
of our audiences researchers who I think
a great deal of our members are today
students I think students are a big part
of our audience that we really haven't
talked about much today for what this
project might mean and I was thinking
about there's this there's this project
called making it matter and they really
focused on how can data and link data be
of benefit to third world countries and
the educational countries I'm thinking
about that as yet or not as a possible
audience for the open syllabus project
and how to make these data available to
them as as another way to use this this
wonderful corpus that we're putting
together here now there are a lot of
examples out there in the science world
about collections of data and the
communities that are built around data
and one of these is a protein databank
right and so one of the things they have
worked for ages about collecting
information about protein and protein
structures and through this project of
the protein database they've been able
to establish a community that
corresponds with each other and sees the
value in submitting these data to this
general collective area right this very
focused database for in this case
protein there's another one that's great
for nanotechnology and nano materials
that again they've looked at ways to to
talk with their community and to build
that community in all the different ways
and you can see if you can if you go to
that side if you can see here all the
different things that they have there
they have electors that are built around
these these data they have tools they
have both their iOS and Android apps out
there for exploring all of the
information that they've been able to
collect here and really adding value
value to that type of information as
well which I think is one of the
foundations for having you develop a
community and he's not gonna build
around something it doesn't have any
value for anyone so that's one of the
ideas that would encourage everyone here
to think about especially going into the
hackathon tomorrow the non-technical
half decide about the ideas that you can
develop around so really who are our
audiences and what things might they
find useful out of this and I'm going to
talk a little bit about more about that
because I think one of the the other
ways of building community is making
sure that not only do people find value
in the work that you're doing but the
people who are doing the work are
getting credit for the work that they're
doing and I'll talk a little bit about
that later on but one of the first steps
to building this community and having
all of these data types work together is
interoperability right the gears have to
mesh together and I think part of part
of this is being worked on through the
type of database that's been set up the
the denotes equal amount Mongo database
that's being used and that idea of a
flexible schema structure that's being
built around that so we're not locked
into one thing but different parts of
information can be pulled out for
different queries and different research
questions that can be asked but one of
the important parts about this is that
to think about and to keep in mind that
when you are performing research on
these data that you want to be able to
not just for your own concern to go back
and see but what's that question that I
asked and what did I ask that question
of and this goes back to the point that
Jonah brought up earlier today about so
we have this constantly evolving set of
information how do you how do you
identify what that was when you ask your
question of it how can you go back and
confirm that you'd get the same question
or that your algorithm works in the same
way and so these are some of the issues
I encourage you to think about as when
you think about this corpora as a data
set in and of itself is how do you
uniquely identify what you ask the
question of how do you really CLE
identify what your question was
because if for instance you're you're
asking your question through a coding a
coded query right and languages change
so you want to be able to document all
of these things and always keep in mind
when this is when this is true that your
metadata is a love note to the future
we're not just talking about the
metadata associated with that data set
right we're also talking about how are
you describing how you ask your question
what part of that data set did you ask
the question of was it the whole dataset
was a part of the data set was it the
data set at a certain date and time what
were the the software that were in
operation at that point around the data
set and I think Dennis had brought up
that they take snapshots of the database
and I don't see them up there since they
take snapshots Kenneth right of the
database so weekly or daily or things
like that so one of the things I would
encourage you to think about is when
taking those snapshots don't just take
that snapshot give that snapshot and
identifier so someone at some point can
go back in time and say I asked the
question of this this snapshot right
here not this one over here but this one
right here so that you can not only go
back and replicate your answers but also
do really informed comparisons of how is
the data is it different when you ask
that same question of it and how does
influence how your results are different
so something to think about as we move
this project forward now one of the
other things that we always we're
dealing with every day as a challenge no
matter what we're doing is academics is
one of that revolution right one of you
know how are you getting credit how is
everyone's contributing to this project
getting
for that and citation is needed citation
is needed at every single step of the
way and I think this is really an
important thing that can be added into
this project so everyone is getting
recognized to what they've put into it
whether it is a professor that has
submitted a syllabus is there a way for
them because they've completed it to
this project that they can then get an
identifier out of it so they can get
credit to it and make sure you're going
to talk more about this later on are
educate 'ln so I will leave that there
for the researchers but also for
everyone who's contributing code and
script for them to get credit for that
as well as part of their own research
output in a their own research endeavors
and I think it's this type of thing that
will help the project build a community
become more sustainable and eventually
we hope that move beyond just the sense
of building of hearts list to really
understand more about what the
educational endeavor is to move beyond
knowing it takes X Y and C and
understanding why X Y & Z can work
together to achieve the things the
things that they have achieved in that
particular setting
so going from parts to pathways and I'm
up next
at the core to reach all right see if
this works
all right so I probably have 20 slides
but I want to I want to get through in
ten minutes and a good part is a lot of
these topics I think I already covered
today my slides are online on speaker
deck on the QR code if you want to
follow our our H MacDonald on speaker
deck a little bit about the a CRC
mission one of the future slides on this
really gets you to want to think about
that for open syllabuses you know
identifying that mission up front so
you're not you know recreating the wheel
and something that isn't even part of
your mission and I heard some good
things about that today in terms of
discovery it's not part of your mission
right now great find a collaborator to
help with that discovery you're already
looking at that with with other folks at
Penn State and there's some other great
groups to probably talk to about that
kind of element and if you build your
infrastructure right you know that kind
of collaboration can happen all the time
the ECR sea is a public research arm of
the Hadi trust we enable terascale text
data mining and analysis of the hydros
collection we develop tools for that
purpose we also work with to develop
cyber infrastructure for those tools to
run across a high-performance computing
resources and we enable community for
scholars who are working with our tools
and with the infrastructure that we have
in place key thing to keep in mind for
us we are a research center owned by
Indiana University and University of
Illinois we operate under the auspices
of the University of Michigan because
that's where the legal agreements are
all kind of found for the Hadees fest
corpus so we work directly with hottie
trust under University must care for
that and then a lot of the things that
we're unable to do is because each of
our institutions are under an MoU with
Google to work with the content that
they actually digitized so if you really
looked into the rice and the policies
issues of some of the things we're
working on you could spend probably
three hours on that so I won't go into
it the challenges though that we've had
on this and we go back a long ways with
Hadi Trust Research Center we started
working on this in oh nine and one of
the reasons it took so long of course is
some of those intellectual property
agreements the the other side to this
was the
the Google Books ongoing saga in the
court system that kind of slowed some
things down and kind of redirected some
of our funding into other other areas
that didn't quite appear for us but we
put together our initial kind of RFP to
support the center in O 9 of 10 then
Illinois and Indiana came in to put in a
bid on that around 10 sometime and then
11 we move that forward but the
challenge is that that you heard some
from Miao Chen today with with our
community components and whether also
with some of our technical challenges
but the pieces there on the community
the pieces are on the infrastructure
having a healthy ecosystem that really
extends beyond just our institutional
based funding and goes out into areas
with with partnerships and commercial
areas as well as partnerships with other
hoti trust members other universities
those are all key things and then the
sustainability piece I've got a slide on
that but all I'm going to tell you about
it is to have lots of different revenue
streams in terms of that sustainability
component because relying just on a
smaller community for base funding well
of course keep you going for a while
while you're gearing up our Indy tract
for for other types of governmental and
private funding but it's being able to
expand in that community further and
further the hoti trust itself has close
to 95 members now and now and moving
forward we just were approved funding so
that there's actual funding coming from
the Hadi trust membership as well as
from Illinois and Indiana as well as
lots of Broadus infrastructure coming
from both Illinois and Indiana to make
what we do possible the ecosystem there
for us institutional support commercial
support governmental support private
nonprofit support and particularly that
collaborative support how are we going
to scale how is that going to drive out
to the community you're serving and of
course all that needs to relate back to
your mission I'm gonna put this in and
I'm not going to talk about it much but
I do think it's something to think about
anytime you're looking at these
communities our CEO Brad wheeler
developed this chart along with now the
University Librarian at university of
michigan james hylton
and what he started doing is looking at
how things kind of pulled out both from
a community source
a framework within higher ed from what
they call a community source kind of
framework within higher ed typical types
of contracts that you know large
institutions enter in for the enterprise
and other kinds of support and then what
they call kind of buying clubs kind of
like JSTOR and other things that
libraries typically are involved in and
that's one of the other hats I wear
during other parts of the day but what
this ecosystem fit
I put of course a lot of you'll realize
these are directors five questions about
you know your startup because when you
look at what you're doing it's a whole
lot like a startup you just have
different types of base funding from
your angel investors than you would get
if you were out there on your own
forming a business and looking at that
mission who is that customer what is the
customer value what are the results that
you want to see with your product and
what's the plan to get you to those
results those all help you frame both
the fit of the ecosystem as well as the
ecosystem that you really need to move
forward the infrastructure piece I heard
great things today so it sounds like you
guys have some wonderful advice coming
to you about what you're already setting
up and how you're taking it forward but
it's really about you know the
portability of how you set up that
infrastructure and I listed there
infrastructure as a service it's great
that you guys are looking at something
like Amazon and how you can move your
components around and the cloud but also
think about what happens when you scale
beyond Amazon affordability on Amazon
especially for your data because that's
what's gonna hang you up and are you
looking at the other open as components
you could put in place like if say a
large high performance computing center
came in and said okay we'll give you
data storage space a compute space how
would you move your virtual environments
into that environment using something
like OpenStack or eucalyptus that's kind
of the next level question beyond where
you are with with Amazon the scalability
for that looking at you know more of a
service-oriented architecture you're
looking at restful interfaces it looks
like for your your web services how does
that scale longer-term already heard
great stuff about production versus test
versus development I run lots of
projects where I'm doing R&D kinds of
stuff and it's all testy and prototype
II and so forth when I run other
products to support the entire IU system
and they have to be enterprise I have a
production version a test version and a
complete development version
and neither the twain shall meet because
my production version has to be up a lot
of the time because I have you know
probably like five 500 to 600 staff that
rely on the systems to do their business
every day of the week the development of
the community infrastructure is a big
piece and you know these kind of
meetings help drive that because people
get to meet each other and see each
other and see the projects they're
working on but how do you take that over
into you know the long-term year-to-year
online environment for support and
driving you know the next challenge is
Grand Challenges that you have one of
the things we've done with hoti Trust is
get funding from the mellon foundation
to drive MINI CHALLENGE grants to get
people to look at work set creation and
extraction from our larger set and over
time that's gonna you know give us a
corpus of research to show what we can
do especially when we start mining the
full collection we've been mining the
the kind of incop in public collection
right now to test out our prototype
we'll be moving to the full collection
in the next few months and and that
really took a lot of security auditing
around what we're doing so we could
prove the University of Michigan that we
were matching the the kind of elements
they were offering to secure the content
and that's the kind of thing that you
can't do if you don't have a production
environment where it's production test
development if you don't have that then
you can't always answer those kinds of
questions when you look at that room now
of course what you guys are talking
about doesn't have kind of the
constrictions that they were under with
with how to trust the other big pieces
as you scale how do you connect to the
in-kind or the most available high
performance computing or cluster
resources that could be available to you
just from the community that you're in
because you're attached to a major
university and you're attached to groups
that are attached to places like NSF how
can you utilize those and get your cost
down over the long term versus just
paying strictly each Amazon or somebody
for that depends on what you're doing
with the resources of course the
community I already mentioned the
functional the technical and I listed to
user groups here both your physical one
when you have events like this or a user
group meeting but the the virtual one
that's online that's that's how you're
supporting people longer-term to use
your collection and having a
outreach component where you're having
both the WebEx online types of meetings
and discussions with your community as
well as the in-person one that's that's
going to be key for driving people to
develop for your platform to develop
using services for your content and
doing mix and remix of your content over
time sustainability really I just wanted
to have this in there thinking about the
multiple income streams thinking about
where your umbrella support is I worked
with a lot of projects on the
sustainability issue groups like the
bebo project groups like quality open
library environment we've taken
different paths than say Hadi Trust has
Hadi Trust is still in there an umbrella
of the University of Michigan I think
that's a real viable path for a lot of
things and I think that's one that
everyone should consider other places
for a while we're trying to build their
own 501c3 around everything I really
think that's a bad idea if you can find
one that could support you with the
right umbrella both for you know what
you need internally to do your work
whether it's your setups for your
repositories and your communications and
your confluence kind of stuff for your
developers and then whether they have
ongoing user group meetings that you can
piggyback on to so you can get the cost
down to get you know to have longer-term
user group meetings those are all key
things and so my big lessons out of all
of this is think before you build which
you guys have obviously done build for a
production service model even if you're
not doing it right away think you know
how about in mind a plan for it enable a
diversity ecosystem for support and that
really means figuring out who in the
commercial community might be part of
that ecosystem because out of all these
groups that I've worked with every time
the ones that seem to have the longest
life in them really have found the right
kind of niches to support services from
a commercial element that are around
them and they still remain open they
still remain community stores or open
source whatever they're doing with their
software but they're finding the right
kind of service providers and and
sometimes you know that it's not always
the first people that talk to you it's
the third or fourth or fifth that become
that ecosystem and then the diversity of
funding streams so that was really quick
but it also kind of highlighted a lot of
great things were going on here today
that I heard you know from all these
great talks that we've seen some
or so we can have questions or we can
move on to the next speaker
possibly yeah the the raw data so the
raw data all came an aggregate from
Google scans from basically the project
that they set up originally for Google
Books and and the idea was to say in the
University of Michigan library and fall
now the interesting part about that
anytime you want to do that to a library
there's always gonna be something that
was missing it wasn't collected at the
right period of time it got lost along
the way so then when they started having
their other partner members like the
libraries of the Big Ten CIC grew they
started doing collection analysis on it
saying okay we have all of this but
we're missing these so they started
looking at the other libraries that had
them
aiyoo for instance for two years we had
a couple of truckloads a month that went
to the scanning facility and most of
that was just to fill in the gaps of
what was either not on the shelf or
missing long term and Michigan's library
that kind of thing and then there are
also copies of books that were done by
individual libraries that were collected
by hoti trust and that was one of the
incentives for membership was not only
did you get the aggregate access
long-term and storage for preservation
for the google books collection but you
could add to that for volumes that
weren't already there that you might
have already scanned from work you had
done previously for digital libraries so
that's that's really where all the raw
data is coming from there
so right now you know the the stuff with
Google is trickling down but we're using
the same interface that they developed
which is called dren and that's how the
libraries continue to contribute volumes
that they're scanning moving forward no
no this is this all came from basically
you know a scanning process similar to
what Internet Archive does with their
book scanning but Google has some twists
and turns on that that made it more
efficient that's of course Google
property so what but it's an interesting
process yeah alright and we've got the
same we got a slide deck and this was
going to just slide over if that's okay
okay yeah
I had trouble kind of 20 more times so
I'm just
yeah open learning analytics is one of
the initiators that we are associated
with it's it's it's kind of a combined
effort between two groups I just started
out recently a pareo Foundation is one
of the groups and I'm wearing a pareo
hat as well today and solar is another
research community which kind of has
been doing considerable amount of work
in the field of learning analytics they
host regular conferences if you are
familiar with learning analytics and
knowledge conference it kind of tracks
like international audience a group of
researchers of actually a broad spectrum
of people in terms of their expertise
coming from a variety of fields trying
to tackle the common problem of how do
we track how learners are you know
learning in the particular environment
and how do we enrich the experience and
okay my name is sandy Jeff Rakesh and
I'm learning analytics specialist of
NARAS College and I also work closely
with the open source community
the aperio foundation a little bit of
context about both of the you know
groups out here if people are not
familiar with either of these what in
this particular initiative what we try
to do is try to define and create like
what goes into creating the learning
analytics software which is completely
open source and available for wide scale
adoption
we also plan define standards around
various use cases in terms of developing
targeted learning analytics software and
we also deal with open models like how
do we share the
insights and models and algorithms that
we have created how do you make that
portable how can now when you make that
you know deploy in a wide range of
settings and provide integrations with
wide range of platforms out there in
terms of LMS or any other any other
applications and we also have like a
series of journals and avenues where we
regularly make publication efforts so
that we disseminate knowledge across the
community so everyone is aware of what's
going on and we move forward without a
lot of duplication of effort and we keep
each other in touch about like various
projects that are going on and provide
more opportunities for collaboration and
it is definitely not anti commercial and
that that is one of the one of the
important aspects the commercial
ecosystems have been sustainability of
the open-source communities as well so
yeah it's completely open source
initiative everyone is free to come and
associate with us our you know I there
are like mutual areas of collaboration
we would love to talk more really
regarding that ok much of the work that
has been done in terms of analytics or
is kind of more focused towards a
specific goal and it has not been like
widely adopted or widely available for
all of the folks out there to kind of
dig into it or test it out in their
environment and see how it works right
so that's why we made an effort to
collaborate more towards this particular
approach and see like how we can create
more openness in terms of sharing all of
these ideas and resources and best
practices and
you know what kind of issues we can
mitigate together or recovering and of
use cases and all those problems are
something about which we try to tackle
in this particular initiated some of the
goals were more towards like documenting
what are the domains that we should be
looking at in terms of creating more
openness in the field itself in the data
mining of educational data mining and
content analysis feed itself identify
the current landscape and how we can
engage with each other with minimal
minimal duplication and create more
reference implementations and evidence
hubs where people can come forward and
try each other each other innovations
and test it out in their environments
and also networking and collaboration is
one of the major goals mmm let's go
through a couple of slides and just give
a brief background about infamous
okay solar the acronym is Society for
learning and addiction research their
main interest it's a combined interest
is to create more like a common
framework an Apache Commons model there
you know we have best practices
available and standards available
everyone is working together in terms of
you know trying to identify what tools
work best in what scenarios how do we
provide the success rate for each of the
frameworks that is available out there
that kind of an approach where we we
don't necessarily say that oh follow one
particular architecture or something
like that but we provide more details as
to what kind what kind of architecture
works best
what kind of frameworks work best in
your particular setting and yeah it
basically we are looking at the creation
of a comments model for analytics which
is most for most part platform neutral
so each of the companies can be plugins
which are interacting with each other as
long as we are sharing data in common
formats like JSON or XML which can be
ingested by majority of the tools or
software's that are available out there
aperio it was a merger between two
open-source communities out there Sakai
which is one of the learning management
system a completely open source platform
which is which has a global presence in
terms of
logical deployment in terms of higher
education and Jacek is another platform
which develops tools within higher
education and both of these recently
like last year collaborated and combined
their efforts together to form a pareo
basically the merge together to form a
fairy oh that's a little bit of
background of some of the projects that
are available within the up area
foundation Sakai that is the LMS
platform there are a lot of portlet
projects and authentication frameworks
Student Success plan is more towards
intervention and oae is more towards
academic collaboration bringing research
communities together providing out of
classroom experience for all the users
students faculties researchers to
collaborate better you know in a more
social socially interactive setting and
like I said it has a global presence out
there with majority of focus in North
America and Australia and Africa 80% of
French universities are kind of
currently running on Sakai so there is a
lot of data that is being generated that
there are opportunities for us to
analyze so well we recently kick-started
the learning analytics initiative our
major goal was to have the research meet
a sustainable model fairly quickly
operationalize some of the software's
and api's and standards that are being
developed as a part of the open learning
analytics open learning analytics summit
itself so these were some of the
institutions that actually participated
that actually kick-started this
particular
initiated the University of Amsterdam
they've been working more towards data
collection and storage basically
streaming data from a wide range of
sources in terms of Esaias LMS social
settings like Twitter feeds and Facebook
what they are into is bringing all of
this data together into one common
repository called learning record store
which provides an opportunity for unless
and researchers like me to go there and
build applications which is kind of we
just and unloved as to the model dennis
was explaining there we once all the
data is collected and that we have
performed all Dean in how to ingest this
particular data we can write data
adapters where we are sending out
targeted data to each of the
applications which can be an app store
model of a variety of analytical
solutions like it can be your retention
solutions trying to predict like who are
the students who are address our it can
be more towards content analysis what is
the quality of submissions or just like
social network analysis of um what kind
of learning patterns are emerging within
the social network how people are
interacting with each other so a wide
range of solutions are available within
the app store model and the next
learning analytics self conference is
going to be held at Marist College which
is an hour and a half from here upstate
New York and we have a beautiful campus
and we expect all of you
participate in this particular survey
we'll also have the open learning
analytics summit and a hackathon which
is going to be pre conference or post
conference we are still working on the
details on that but that would be
another avenue where people who are who
have similar interests like the OSB
project out here where tomorrow in the
hackathon you are trying to define the
open models what goes into creating open
datasets how do we share the data and
everything it is gonna be pretty much
the same thing we had the last summit in
Indianapolis right after the last 14
conference and that's where we defined
the various domains like the five
domains in terms of open models and you
know open to software what goes into
creating the plug-in model creating more
architectures and frameworks defining
ethics and privacy and the policies
related to that so it's pretty much the
same setting the core concept so it
would be great to have like more
participation and who have like similar
interests and similar approaches and
getting a wide range of inputs in order
to take it forward as a community itself
any questions comments
yeah
well actually both but both of the
continents are involved at this point we
are analyzing data like I said from the
student information systems where it is
mostly demographics and static data
which doesn't change over a semester and
learning management system data because
your event logs any kind of submissions
or assignments tests and quizzes forums
so that generates a lot of content as
well which we can dig into in terms of
more more into text mining and NLP where
we are trying to assess the quality of
the submissions of the students that is
none other dimension there is also
interests within community to look at
more into the MOOC data that is also no
sequel of a kind of data so that is
another dimension where we are trying to
create more reference implementations
and targeted applications to much
okay
are you there
I think so what I think it was off the
screen from before
that are good hope you don't eat so my
name is Jody Ratner and I'm the founder
of a company that's basically
specialized in syllabi for about the
last six seven years so a lot of the
conversation that I've heard today are
definitely things that we have heard
before of course our interests are have
maybe been a little bit different
because of the fact that we are a
for-profit but when it comes to
intellectual property when it comes to
adoption integration all of these types
of things are frankly things that we've
encountered before so why don't to do
today is spend a few minutes describing
those in fact we've actually touched
upon so many of them I'll probably go
through the slides quickly but then
showcase our tool also because if since
the discussion came up before about
should the data be more structured what
kinds of schema might you approach with
it this will probably demonstrate what
is the ultimate in terms of a framework
for a syllabus schema again I wouldn't
necessarily recommend that this
particular project actually go that far
but when you see it you'll see why so a
little bit about us though we've Intel
edenia is kind of hard to to to say so
we have become affectionately the
syllabus geeks so we've been doing this
for quite some time we now have clients
across the United States and abroad I
happen to be here in New York the other
offices in California and we really have
I believe become thought leaders in this
particular space and what we had
recognized very early on in terms of
trends is that there are many more
applications for the syllabi these days
certainly one in terms of the syllabus
as a contract and that's kind of what it
has traditionally been described as but
then we were seeing that it was being
utilized in a much more assessment
oriented way specifically accreditation
or often accreditation and then when we
talk about marketing we're really
talking about the marketing of the
actual classes and whether that be among
your current community of students to
prospective students to other faculty
members so the drivers for that we found
were a focus on outcomes B legislation
in here we are primarily talking about
House bill 2504 which has come up a
number of times today in Texas and then
at this point just ubiquitous access so
even the idea of getting your syllabus
mobile device is something that is
expected of today's students but
certainly not supported by most of the
current forms so what institutions have
been doing is they have taken a more
institutional approach to managing
syllabi this is more like having master
templates which maybe define a course
description or the course description
comes from the course catalog where
outcomes are predefined in such a way
that you know the instructors are
starting off with some boilerplate
language and in fact the the range that
we find our tool is designed to be
flexible in this respect but we will
find clients largely the for-profits in
the community colleges which is our
bread-and-butter whereby with large
percentages of adjunct faculty members
and a teaching focus they are absolutely
going after this sort of master template
approach I think many of you in the room
are probably thinking much more on the
other side or come from environments
that are on the other side where faculty
freedom is really the area that is of
more concern or the ability for
instructor to actually design their
syllabus however they may be but in a
lot of our cases it's very much a sort
of structured approach and schools are
introducing technological solutions
whether they build it in-house whether
they adopt something like concourse so
that the types of tools then you guys
are also working on I want to make that
a little bit more salient by providing
this is what Shepherd University puts
out and once they basically have here in
the four different colors there some of
the things that are considered federally
mandated some that are West Virginia
mandated some that are mandated by
Shepherd and then things that are open
for instructors and as you can tell this
is not necessarily a very technological
solution and of course instructors can
go in there and can manipulate certain
policies like a TA they don't
necessarily have to follow only the
black or whatnot and our tool comes to
help in this respect so what does sort
of happen is that there's this all
hands-on syllabus on syllabi and the
reason that we talk about the fact that
this is the life cycle of a syllabus is
that if you think about the document
from end to end it goes through some
kind of development that approval it may
have a template form it might get
audited again that's I know it's
somewhat scary word too maybe some of
the institutions that are represented
here but I can promise and many of our
client situations they are looking
precisely at every single instructors
Cilla
to check it off before it even goes
public then it comes into its
instructional mode and then there's some
degree of analysis the reason I put this
number down here too is that for many
institutions because of how spread out
these these things can be and the
different people that are involved our
research has told us that around to a
quarter million dollars a year is
invested in the management of actual
settlement so it's it's probably not as
researched is maybe some of the folks in
this room might do but it is it comes
from a combination of surveying of deep
surveying and a number of different
institutions that we looked at their
infrastructural costs we looked at the
amount of time that deans spent on
syllabi whether it be via reviewing them
we looked at the curriculum development
process we looked at the amount of
instructors time to develop a new
syllabus to maintain the syllabus
throughout the semester and and that was
the number that we arrived at so that
would largely be for a school around
4,000 students is how that got scaled
right that was actually after hours but
yes they they have noted that reduce
sometimes it's hard I mean we've done
this we primarily motivated from a sales
approach because we need to demonstrate
the school they're wasting money in some
kind of way but of course in many
university settings like professor time
is just regarded as free and so that you
can become hard so the organizations are
the most interested have these types of
characteristics for a more structured
approach the syllabi and that they may
have multiple campuses lots percent are
high percentage of engine faculty
members they're much more teaching
focused standardized particular rapid
growth maybe they have a lot of online
programs so most of our clients sort of
look like this I do want to spend a few
minutes actually showcasing the tool so
to succinctly describe it though it's an
online syllabus solution to organize
share and analyze life of syllabi so I
jump out of this and I head over to the
actual system for a moment here we can
see that I'm only
point out a couple of features today in
this demo is available if you want to go
to syllabus geeks comm and actually play
around with it a little bit you can do
that as well
but this is our syllabus solution so
after logging in I'm gonna just go
through two different examples here we
have two essentially the editions of the
product one which is designed to consume
PDFs and Word documents it scrapes the
text it makes them searchable and and
that's actually may even be an
interesting play with respect to this
given group because this is you know
what we do it may not be as fully
functional in terms of things like an
API because that's a decision that we
made given the proprietary nature of our
business but I at least want to showcase
what what we can do so if I pick on art
history here this is just going to load
essentially a syllabus this is not
terribly fancy but what's interesting
about this is you given are other
features of auditing and search and
being able to embed it with a learning
management system we can really drive
adoption rates once there's a button
inside the LMS that's a syllabus and
they're putting it right into the
central system what everyone will
probably find far more interesting here
is that this is our interpretation after
half a decade of work of essentially
what the structure of a syllabus should
look like so after looking at thousands
of these they all generally have an area
that's called meeting times one that's
called contact information we have a
degree of nesting of the data in terms
of the presentation but this is a
database driven solution so behind the
scenes there's actually a table that
represents each of these different
elements so again for what you're doing
in terms of the research world and how
you're you know developing your schemas
this could very well be like the holy
grail of all of the data that you want
to get out I'm gonna showcase after this
how you can run a report that will
specifically pull out the outcomes part
of every single syllabus no question
about you know whether or not it's
outcomes or not or so forth
you're not that's that's true
right so this is an authoring tool the
next thing I'll show you is that the
reason it's maybe a little bit different
than just a straight you know it's not a
word experience I'll show what it is in
a second but the reason is that the
development of syllabi our tool are
largely based on a template structure so
the Provost will fill out a piece of the
syllabus and then Dean's can fill out
more pieces of the syllabus and then a
curricula person fills out more pieces
so what the instructor normally inherits
it's not something they have to start
from end to end it will have a lot of
information on it already so but anyway
in terms of the different components so
but we call them items you've got
description materials and so we have a
structure that we can discuss maybe
tomorrow and how well this this fits but
I do want to show editing and I do want
to show reporting before finishing up so
when I go to edit a given syllabus we
have this side-by-side experience and is
this form driven so if I wanted to come
in here I wanted to update say my my
lecture time I click this yellow edit
button and were presented with a form so
you can imagine that every one of these
forms is essentially matched to a
database table so later on if you want
to see specifically how many people
offer office hours between the hours of
2:00 and 3:00 o'clock we can even do
that with our data set so you can come
here you can update it another question
about this sort of dynamic nature of
syllabi we inherently support that we we
think that the right approach is to have
syllabi evolve over their semester so at
the end of the given semester it's a
accurate representation of what was
happening in the given classroom just to
scroll down here before I get the
reporting and search you'll notice that
there were tools are absent to the left
side of the course description that is
the enforcement of our permission so you
can essentially have parts of the
syllabus that at least now that I'm
meaning the shoes of an instructor are
not necessarily editable and the same
would be true all the way down in the
bottom for institutional policies so for
each of these given items you can
determine should an instructor be able
to come in here edit that piece not that
piece should they get a default for it
and then be able to embellish it those
sorts of things okay so I'm getting
close to wrapping up here I know I
talked about
let's briefly me and I won't go more
into that at this point but again it's
this type of structure where you can
build this tree if you will of syllabus
documents and that's how most why most
institutions are interested but I'm
gonna finish up here by showcasing our
reporting tool so when I pick an item
report this is going to demonstrate
essentially what the full tree looks
like for this particular instance and at
this point if I wanted to get outcomes I
would click on outcomes I click Next and
then presented with our search tool you
can do full sex search for me here or if
you want to you can drop down this
advanced menu and you get to the some of
the more typical parameters like what
semester it was offered when instructor
in this case I'm just going to search
for everything and I'm gonna against all
these results I'm gonna say I want just
the outcomes and here it wasn't a table
of just the outcomes that are
represented on that given syllabus and
if you want more information and there
are many more columns to this you can
download as it as a CSV for additional
detail so that's the end of the formal
demo I guess I think I may have wrong
direction so I want to talk just these
three points about what we've learned
and then wrap up so one we're a business
that's true but we absolutely
underestimated how much how it is to
sell to not only institution I mean we
were going first after instructors but
institutions as a whole
very very very challenging syllabi come
and all say shapes and sizes we've
talked about that today
I do sincerely believe that
standardization has its value but it
certainly does not come easily or
naturally it's where we spend most of
our implementation energy because you
have to imagine a provost has to be
willing to say it's going to be called
outcomes it's not going to be called
learning outcomes it's not gonna be
called objectives and that is you know a
discussion in and of you know five
meetings of a faculty committee just to
come up with if it's outcomes learning
outcomes whatever so I think that it is
absolutely important to utilize a common
taxonomy because I really think this
could be you hugely beneficial how easy
it is to actually develop that type of
taxonomy is is a different question but
that's certainly you know one of the
things that we've learned so to wrap up
we remain available to help largely of
course interested in the technology
elements even though we can speak to
many of these different topics access to
a congress platform is on the table and
i think maybe the most interesting thing
would be to develop an actual standard
for the interchange of structured
syllabus data so any questions for me
it's somewhere in the order of two to
three hundred thousand and again these
are all structured documents so the
level of detail is quite deep and we
also know that there is far less
duplication than there might be in these
other efforts why is selling to
education hard well you need a lot of
consensus a lot of buy-in they if you
think of it purely in the business sense
you would think that they have a lot of
money but oftentimes they say they don't
they're expecting a level of performance
that maybe an Oracle or a Cisco would
provide but they want the education
price we only sell to education so we
can't you know like Dell just come in
and offer those same types of prices so
from a business standpoint I could
sometimes be hard we have challenges
with getting to the right decision maker
because the decision maker is actually
hundreds of decision makers so for
somebody who's gonna say I'm gonna put a
system in I mean you could just picture
this in the Columbia sense how much
inertia or energy you would actually
take for the entire organization to say
I'm gonna adopt this standard structure
for syllabi and everybody's going to use
it I'm gonna integrate it with your LMS
here it's it's just an arduous arduous
test and I think also maybe we were a
little bit early when we started out on
this
I think you know many of these other
surrounding initiatives have made it a
much more attractive proposition for a
school to move this direction at this
point so we do when we don't largely our
version control comes from the fact that
schools have the ability to make copies
when they so choose so an example of
that is it actually maybe if I back up
here this will help me explain this is
going way too fast
okay this is an example of our template
structure and you can see that you have
institution to college courses you could
like build out these but the point at
which we actually do cloning that's
essentially taking a snapshot of the
syllabus and from that point on the
purple is effectively what the
instructor would be using so the reason
that that we do things this way is to
make sure that future syllabus policies
I'll use a very trite example let's just
assume Columbia decided that cheating is
going to be allowed next semester you
wouldn't necessarily want that policy to
show up on previous syllabi especially
from the contractual element so the kind
of versioning that we have going on here
is that we're essentially taking
snapshots of master templates for every
given term and then we walk through the
versions of syllabi but contain if you
will within that given course okay I
think you had your hand
right so you you're you're right I mean
it's it's we are a SAS tool so actually
it's not as segmented as the schools may
believe that we are but because they all
have a common code base but yes they do
have actual separate databases now the
other question about exposure maybe also
has to do with weather and the publicity
of it so a number of the schools that we
have like Alamo and Glen are examples of
institutions whereby they have to make
everything public because of this
legislation in the first place so if you
went into our tool you could you could
find all of those you know
instantaneously but some other schools
are much more tight you know looked
about depends on what you captured I
mean we've been we've been supporting
them for years at this point so I have
to imagine that might have come out that
way
so so yeah there's a is essentially a
pretty big separation between what we
call of course and what we call a
syllabus the syllabus to us is the
content in core that incorporates the
description the outcomes the schedule
the effectively the administrative
structure of the course we've heard it
called paths before I mean there's a
number different terms the us course
level data is going to include when it's
offered what its title is and whatnot
and so those are the kinds of things
were at least number of standards per se
exist the right to my knowledge there is
not any kind of syllabus standard when I
also think about standards I also think
about the integration points that we
have and largely in order to work with
the learning management system it's
things like learning tools
interoperability or LTI which we are
absolutely compliant out with in fact we
actually started a second business that
specializes purely on third-party
integration with learning management
systems and because of how challenging
it they call it a standard but I promise
you the way it's implemented is nothing
close to it so more on on our
integration if you want but stars a
syllabus standard I don't believe one
exists don't assign hand
in ingestion in the way that it's been
described here not so much but for
example when these colleges come to us
we sometimes have gone through
migrations so we will take like
curricunet data and find a way to map
curricunet structure to what we already
have and it works most of the time but
it's not perfect but we don't
necessarily have any kind of you know
like intelligent syllabus analyzer that
was able to like just consume a syllabus
and then produce it in its structured
form I think if that existed you know
usual to us but no so the historical
approach that we take is like the PDF I
showed in the beginning which is still
very valuable again we I think as a
business we went too far in the
beginning because if you say to is like
it's a huge leap even for a school to
have a central syllabus database of PDFs
and we want to do outcome linking and we
automatically notify students when a
syllabus is updated and we have calendar
integration so you can bring your
syllabus and you can actually sync it
with Google Calendar for most schools I
want to just get a repository together
and that's like step one
syllabi in your
is it is it I actually was not even
aware of that effort even until earlier
today you know art are struck it's a
database-driven
it's a post stress solution so it's you
can't necessarily like export an XML
version or a JSON version that's exactly
what I'm talking about when I think
about the development we've we've
actually experimented somewhat with that
but at the end of the day even if we
allowed syllabi to comment as JSON we
didn't know of any other solutions that
would consume it and from a business
perspective of course that also can be
anti due to what we were doing so at
this point I'd like to do that kind of
development but it hasn't materialized
yet too much more complicated but as far
as like where our syllabi are going
there's been some hints today about how
they're increasingly contractual
administrators are having today but you
know we looked at any at this historical
you know the beautiful graphic novel one
and you know a couple things that are
coming to my mind in terms the word
think you're going or things like video
you know in a lot of moves that the
description of the course is now
offering video and I think that Duke the
students on campus are demanding that
kind of explanation or description for
their courses on campus - I can imagine
I've been in courses where the students
themselves in the course of the semester
dynamically help create what they're
going to study saying the second half of
the semester you know you incorporate
some elements of you know change
so I'm wondering like is it very is a
premature like what are we preclude when
we introduce standards at this point for
example and where do you think this is
going and I think the presumption of it
the text-based
static syllabus is so a few things we do
find people who do interesting things
with our tool I'll say that in quotes
but you know some of them are saying
that images they embed videos and
whatnot and our our tool supports that
kind of thing I think maybe the bigger
question is essentially what is the like
to stop at the end of the syllabus to
the beginning of the learning
environment and granted the syllabus is
oftentimes embedded as a part of the
learning environment but if you're
having some kind of video discussion I
mean does that actually make sense to
have somehow related to the syllabus or
should the syllabus just say on this
given day we're going to be doing video
discussions here is the link to go to
this other place in the LMS where that
is actually captured so again the end of
the syllabus at the beginning of the
course maybe that's even a blurry line
but I think that you're still going to
find I would believe it's still gonna
find that there is a document that
codifies the the implementation of the
course
right so so we are various we are
actually very strong and we take a
position that that's what's going to
happen because often what we would find
is that if schools lock down our syllabi
entirely then instructors would
essentially go around the system and
they start emailing they'd say hey this
test is going to be on Friday instead of
Tuesday or you know whatever it is so we
try to make it as very as easy as
possible for a structure statute this is
the platform and edit the elements of
the syllabus that the school has
determined are actually appropriate for
manipulation manipulating things like a
greeting scheme is a very you don't
really want to do that kind of thing and
I know we've heard about legal you know
earlier today but like when you say that
it test used to be worth 30 percent now
it's worth 10 it's gonna hurt someone so
we make it easy for them to update
throughout the semester we think we
provide the most accurate reflection of
what of course you know is at the end
and then in some cases it probably isn't
an appropriate thing to edit in the
first place
I wanted to start with a personal
anecdote that I thought would be
appropriate for this group my brother's
a physics professor at West Chester
University just outside of Philadelphia
and he had a problem and his problem was
that he felt that the enrollment of his
physics 101 course was a little anemic
that he could have could could do a
better job attracting more students into
taking that physics 101 course so he
tinkered and he changed things around in
the syllabus to see if he could get
attract more non physics students into
his physics 101 course and then he got
tenure and then he went on sabbatical as
many people do after they get tenure and
he decided while on sabbatical to
completely rebuild physics 101 from the
ground up thinking not about the
material but about the student and why
they weren't coming to physics 101 why
they weren't enrolling in that class and
and what can lower that barrier of entry
and this is what he came up with there
he is in the chef's hat and it blew the
barn doors off the problem food fire and
physics the science of cooking with live
demonstrations and a connection between
the recipes and the physics and then a
convivial eating and sharing and
discussing and that blending itself into
a study spontaneous Q&A period etc so I
just wanted to share that with you
because I thought I wanted to underscore
the importance from my perspective of
what you're doing in in in helping
discover examples like this in this
treasure trove of data that is that
you're helping to - unto mine and to
uncover these kinds of gems it's also a
great set up for digital science
Digital science is an incubator we'd
fund companies and the companies we fund
are founded by academics X academics who
decided rather than to write a grant to
see if they could create some to to
implement a project that they they
became interested in or to solve a
problem that they encountered they
decided that they wanted to start a
company because they didn't want to live
grant to grant and they wanted to create
something that was more sustainable and
they wanted to pay their developers and
send them to conferences and do other
sorts of things like that
and and our our space is all of academia
so not just in the laboratory not just
behind the lectern but also in the
Provost's office as well you may already
be aware of some of the companies that
we fund figshare for example which is a
open data repository service that is I
think it's probably the company that has
the most love among academics and that
was founded by a stem cell researcher
who was frustrated that he a tiny tiny
fraction of his research was going to
end up in in the in the literature and
in a published paper and that negative
data had no home and yet that's exactly
the kinds of data that you want to put
out there so people won't repeat the
same experiment that you've already done
well and documented and and or they may
find a positive in your negative data
and then take that into a different
direction and another example is
altmetric we've talked about at various
points today impact and identifying what
types of scholarship are being
incorporated into syllabi and I'll talk
a little bit more about how altmetric is
an out-of-the-box solution for that
problem but what do they mean if you
just remember one thing from the next
four or five slides I'll share with you
it's this that if you have an open
projects that you want to sustain it's
okay to fact it's I would argue to your
advantage to find paying customers
paying customers I know that's a scary
thing to hear in academia who have
problems that are willing to spend money
to solve and connecting that to to your
project and it's okay that a small you
think of it as a Venn diagram that among
all of your users a small circle of
those users might be paying users but
those paying users enable the users that
use your product for free to continue to
use your product and and it enables you
to finance expanding your product
upgrading it and again paying your
developers going to conferences etc so
that's the one thing I would love for
you to take away from this and I'll show
examples a to two case studies in which
there are products that are open and
free for researchers to use that that
the founders have identified paying
customers that helped finance that
project and enable it to be a
self-sustaining company digital science
is as I mentioned we're an incubator we
were spun out of Nature Publishing Group
in about 2010 we are part of a larger
organization macmillan which itself as a
part of Holtz pranks we've many many
many companies and we leverage the fact
that we have friends in different parts
of the organization for example this is
a publication that I collaborated with
my team built a data set and some
visualizations that were published in
Scientific American that we mutually
benefited from each other's strengths so
our innovation and our expertise with
data visualization data mining and their
built-in audience we do have a Grants
program called the catalyst grant it's
very small but it's one model in which
people who don't have
initially commercial application of
their idea can have a play but again the
main theme that I wanted to share is its
how to take that project that's a great
idea and that you want to keep open you
want to keep three for researchers to
use but you also want to have it
sustained and be part it and have a
revenue stream that's independent of a
grant because of course those are not
guaranteed year on year and and how what
is the key to that the key is really
simple find a problem that people are
willing to spend money to solve and so
really what you're doing is you're
looking for pain not nice to have not
that's cool but pain because that's what
people are going to pull out their
credit cards and buy if you've got a
solution for them two case studies
figshare as I mentioned I'm sure some of
you have heard of figshare is is free
for researchers to use if you have done
beautiful experiments and you have
completely negative data and you're not
going to use that data figshare is a
wonderful home for that data you your
data will get a DOI you can it gets
excitable the the platform allows you to
share it with other researchers and it's
completely free
they have privacy options you can make
it private or public it's in the cloud
and how is it possible that this
wonderful service is available for you
to use for free because in that Venn
diagram there's a small set of users
that are have us have a problem that
figshare solves better than any other
solution on the marketplace so for
example many publishers have
supplementary data associated with
articles and that supplementary data is
often just a mishmash of PDFs or a giant
word document with figures in it started
usually very lightly edited but often
for aficionados in the field it's very
critical to be able to access that
supplementary data
and so fix your offers a wonderful
solution to being able to store all that
stuff in the cloud associate it with the
article but allow the publisher to
concentrate on what they do best which
is the article itself and the editing
and the publication and dissemination of
that article figshare also has is
launching a product to solve the problem
that many academics have academic
Institute's have in which they would
like an institutional repository for
data many as as has been mentioned
earlier many government agencies are now
mandating that universities that receive
federal funding provide access to the
data associated with the papers with the
research that's generated from that
federal funding and so figshare is
providing us a plug-and-play solution
for academic Institute's some academic
Institute's want to build their own
repository that's great other academics
Institute's do not want to get into the
business of being hosting data and so
figshare is a is a great solution for
that and again these paying customers
helped make figshare free for individual
users the second case example is
altmetric so metric is a tool that
crawls the web it crawls blogs Twitter
Facebook mainstream media outlets and
looks for mentions of papers usually
links to the paper itself and it uses
the DOI to uniquely identify the paper
and then map on the mentions it picks up
onto that paper and it creates a score
that little called the donut geometric
donut with the number in the middle
represents the different kinds of media
attention associated with that paper and
so publishers want to provide this as a
service to their authors it enables them
to stay competitive with other
publishers people are authors are very
interested to know who's blogging about
their paper who's tweeting about their
paper what what are newspapers have
picked up the story and are writing
about it
and it also enables publishers to have a
dashboard of all of the papers they
published for their journal and which
articles are receiving what kind of
media attention and altmetric is free D
again free to use for an individual
researcher so you can upload a bookmark
a bookmarklet and then if you're looking
at a PDF you can get an OP metric score
for for any any document that any
document that has a PDF so specifically
to the open syllabus project we already
have an out-of-the-box solution
therefore if for the problem of I'd like
to search syllabi for mentions of
research articles and try to understand
and discover what research articles are
being cited by my course by syllabi so
we have that altmetric would be an
out-of-the-box solution for that problem
and as I mentioned before it could
potentially enable researchers to
discover who is using their material in
their courses
researchers otherwise would have no idea
that somebody halfway across the country
is using their their nature reviews
paper as a introduction to what a
canonical HeLa cell is you know cell
biology is like right so metric would
enable that so and I've spoken with you
and he's keen on the sandboxing and
playing with with datasets and I hope I
can I can introduce him to some of you
who might be interested in playing
around with this idea closing thoughts
as I mentioned I think it's a many ideas
are wonderful but as I speaking to us
some folks while we were having lunch it
can end up being a bit of a garden and
you want to weed the garden and you want
to really focus on the things that that
are going to going to be the most
productive most fruitful and so the key
here is to find out what people are
willing what pain people have and how
your how the solutions that you're
building are going to solve real world
problems that people have
and then as you know I you know one of
my hats
has been to run a technical team so in
general I worked with loud XML documents
I've worked a lot of structured data
structures good curation good
documentation really critical API sounds
like congratulations on your API that's
going to enable a lot of playing around
it I think it's also critical to have
committed development partners and
really better to have one or two that
are really in there with you then 15
they're like yeah that's cool we should
do something because what being
conservative with your energy and with
your attention and then lastly
evangelists having people that are you
know may not be from a fancy University
or a fancy company but are just into
what you're doing are your best friends
so taking good care of your evangelists
well will pay dividends in the long term
thank you very much so I guess we could
open it up to the for the altmetrics is
that only tracking documents that have
do is assigned to them is that what yes
cueing on is the digital object
identifier is that so again yes really
important to think about when when
thinking about the OSP a finding those
unique identifiers assigning those
digital object identifiers to either
your data set so those data sets can be
tracked or to the results of whatever
query you put against that data set or
the analytics what you eventually
analyze coming out of that again having
that systematic identifier will lead to
people getting credit for the work that
they've done whether it's you know
assigning the DOI to a piece of code
that helped to query the data set a
particular snapshot of the data set at
that point in time or the results that
came out of applying that algorithm that
code to that data set at that point of
time you want to be able to get credit
you want of the little gate recognition
you want this to go towards your
promotion
you want people to be able to look back
and see what you've done and you want to
be able to look back and see what you've
done probably more importantly than
anything else
so I'm given a reference
extent to which and I'll be blunt in its
organized like a circular firing squad
you know do I need to put it away a
fractal phone version incident
infinitely recursive circular fighting
in the sense that it's an organ that
amended these big cities it's a form of
social organization that in many ways
by a former college not to gloat but at
the same time it's I think it's because
different generations and scholars who
are trying to serve by students
institutions do you know throughout
waters that have been much younger
people yeah I think that's that's an
excellent question I the my approach and
I will admit that I had an intern last
summer from Stanford Business School who
has a PhD in material physics material
science from Northwestern and then he
was at Stanford Business School it's a
real idiot and I think I was his intern
over this summer more than he was my
intern I learned a tremendous amount
from this guy
Brice Mara dig for the record um Bryce
taught me how to do exactly what you're
talking about how to discover pain
points so prior to working with Bryce I
would if we had a we had for example we
were gonna build a digital science of
conference intelligence service to track
invited talks seminars because we wanted
to know who is given talks where we
thought this would be a very valuable
signal of academic esteem especially for
young faculty members who don't have the
big publication record general and so we
invited lots people we had workshop we
talked people are like yeah that sounds
really cool they'll be interesting and
Bryce is like I am completely skeptical
about this project what you need to do
is go find people that are going that
you think are the clients of this
product and talk to them and treat those
interviews like a therapy session I mean
a therapy session as in laibach tell me
how horrible it is
tell me bitch to me tell me all of the
awful things that you have to put up
with and if you don't hear them talking
about this the solution that you have
your product is not going to sell
so the the goal is to go out in vivo to
the people who you think will use or buy
a product and let them tell you how
Harvard's and I guarantee you that even
though these faculty members and
administrators that you work with my
dysfunctional which is definitely
endemic to any organization
public-private dot edu org people will
tell you people will be able to answer
the question what what's the difference
between what you want to do in your role
and what you have to do what what do you
wish you could do and it's the gap
between those two things that are the
pain points that people would love for
somebody else to to solve I hope that
addressed your practice I think it's not
so important
so it's not a light therapy session this
is dealing some pretty hard cases and
people as well who are you know as
disgusted we've seen many different
perspectives also quite of have a sense
that the wind is blowing it's a
complicated ways it may also be dressed
as business so it's it's a very it's a
difficult set of negotiations and I
think that this sort of take away from
what you're saying is that listening
very carefully to those discussions and
also documenting that process of
listening and structuring those kinds of
dialogue you know what areas we do and
do not have covered where are the whole
that are just going to rely on trust
and like Sherman went more questioning
me for you it's it's it's quite
imagination it before is a start to this
a start to play with the OSP corners
hopefully and I know that this Genesis
and the status and search on quite a fly
of searches programmatic that one of the
things that we'll be able to see is the
developmental process of people
searching and the data the process of
people searching for
we'll actually some ways to eat
something have a product
but can you imagine issuing that DOI for
every single Google search that someone
does you know right how do you scale
that if you do a DOI for a sequence of
them over an hour each and this is a
good question and it's a question that a
lot of people especially in the research
data world are are crossing this so how
do how do we capture that that unique
query against a database which is
essentially what we're talking about
right it's an unique query if it's a
database at a point in time is it
appropriate to assign a DOI to that
query is it not different disciplines
are coming up with different answers for
that but I think it's a question that
that does need to be asked depending on
how sensitive a particular discipline is
to having that kind of type of reference
available to having that type of
replication or ability to have the
evidence in order to demonstrate that or
to provide a foundation for that so I
simply encourage people to think about
that as a possibility how would that be
managed what type of platform what type
of infrastructure would be necessary is
that something that this project cares
about is it something to Caitlyn's point
that the users are going to be carrying
about
is to say okay this is the date I did
the query these are the keywords I use
and that that media number that would be
I guess before anyone referring back to
that but they just see what
yeah and if you want to talk to the
person on this subject
her name is Victoria Stodden and she's
right here in via University she lives
and breathes reproducibility absolutely
disability take a look we take every s
Stodden sto DD o n I think SPAD DEA and
her current current project right now is
research compendium and she also worked
previously on run my code which again
dealt with a lot of this and if I'm
correct in understanding that right now
queries are being written to disk this
database are those being stored on
github or anything like that is that the
the point for that yes no who knows okay
right do you have an idea that what I
was going to say I think they can fix
share recently have a host actually get
hug Josh probably kids so an interesting
analogy the Digital Sky Survey
astronomical data set because one of the
first major eyes firmly obsessed with it
with a built in sequel interface they
log queries from essentially day one and
hindsight's because they're doing some
interesting research on essentially how
the Astronomy community were in sequel
you watch so education of queries
progress over time is spectacularly
interesting data set so there are those
kinds of examples as well as you think
about different ways people went what
would engage with and use these kinds of
them this kind of a resource not only do
you want to use those to help improve
the product essentially there may well
be research it becomes a David right so
we've been through the question of how
we begin to extract citations which of
the gold and this data set are the
citations you know they're representing
any number of different formats that may
be partial and there all sorts of
problems in that right but they don't
get a graduate approach promise to start
with from well to my library and search
for helper elements in that library and
sounds like that would be the bookends
all metrics could also be the hook into
sexy and for us probably the key
determinant of where Valley the best is
that the results of that are themselves
building blocks for other kinds of
analysis service so that's information
that static will run your data data set
against our hundred twenty million
articles the cafetaria that will capture
some significant number but then we need
that back in order to provide the
building blocks for other kinds of
analysis comparisons of the curricula
across institutions you know which what
are the science departments spin out any
number of interesting scenarios that
need that citation does so we're both
very seduced by this prospect but also
very concerned that that data come back
to us in some fashion
make it part of the plot yeah no I would
love to connect you with Ewan and his
team there if if they would treat the
syllabi as as a as a data source like
blocks or like any any text and they'll
scan it and they'll find links and
they'll find DIYs most I presume most
researchers are going to put do eyes in
their syllabi right so it's probably a
lot of links to papers and they'll fill
the their scripts will resolve the links
and then find the article and then find
the DOI or the article and then connect
the DOI with document again another
reason why you would need unique
identifiers for those it would be
valuable to have unique identifiers for
the syllabi because it would just make
your table a lot easier very
straightforward process